bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette vidéo où nous allons tenter
de répondre à l'éternelle question
faut-il désigner l'homme de néandertal
sous le binôme homo neandertalensis donc
comme une espèce à part entière ou sous
le trinôme homo sapiens neanderthalensis
faisons de l'homme de néandertal une
sous-espèce de l'espèce homo sapiens et
bien la réponse va certainement vous
surprendre puisque en fait il faudrait
désigner l'homme moderne et je dis bien
moderne par le trinôme homo
neandertalensis sapiens rsa vous en
bouche un coin et en définitive en fait
la conclusion de cette vidéo ça va être
qu'il vaudrait mieux ne pas se poser la
question du tout spoiler alert donc
comment j'en arrive à ces conclusions et
bien je vais suivre deux voies de
discussions la première ça va être de
redéfinir ce que c'est qu'une espèce est
en fait on va discuter de ce que sont
les définition du concept d'espèces
parce que figurez-vous qu'il n'y en a
pas qu'une et ensuite on va discuter de
ce qu'est à naulleau type et en quoi
cela est important dans le débat homo
neandertalensis ou homo sapiens
neanderthalensis donc d'abord la
définition des espèces donc comme je
voulais dit n'existe pas qu'une seule
définition du concept d'espèce il en
existe à peu près autant que de
chercheurs qui se demandent ce qu'est
une espèce bon en réalité il y en a qui
n'y en a pas tant que ça il y en a une
quinzaine il ya une quinzaine de
définition de la notion d'espèce et il y
en a que trois qu'on utilise vraiment
très souvent donc je vais vous parler de
ces trois définitions donc la première
définition de ce qu'est une espèce c'est
la définition génétique donc la
définition que les généticiens utilise
quand il quand ils veulent définir une
nouvelle espèce et cette définition
génétique c'est tout simplement de
regarder les gènes et les séquences
génétiques de les comparer à d'autres
espèces connues et de décider si oui ou
non ces différences sont suffisamment
importantes pour ériger une nouvelle
espèce
donc ça une part d'arbitraire mais en
même temps vous allez voir que toutes
les définitions d'espèces ont une énorme
part d'arbitraire la deuxième définition
de la notion d'espèce c'est la
définition morphologiques celle que nous
utilisons constamment nous
paléontologues
cette définition de l'espèce
morphologiques c'est tout simplement on
regarde
compare les différentes morphologies
donc la morphologie du crâne la
morphologie du pelage la morphologie de
ce qu'on veut des fossiles par exemple
dans le cas des paléontologues et on
décide si les différences morphologiques
sont suffisantes pour ériger une
nouvelle espèce ou pas entre deux
individus
voilà donc ça c'est la définition
morphologiques et encore une fois c'est
très arbitraire puisque c'est en
fonction de la du nombre de quantité de
différence est ce qu on juge que s'est
dit assez différent pour ériger une
nouvelle espèce donc c'est vraiment très
arbitraire et la troisième définition
qui est généralement la moins arbitraire
encore que il ya des cas où elle est
très arbitraire c'est la définition à
laquelle vous êtes habitués et c'est la
définition biologique de l'espèce et
cette définition biologique et bien
c'est tout simplement vous prenez deux
individus vous regarder s'ils peuvent se
reproduire entre eux s'ils le peuvent
est-ce que leur descendance est viable
et si cette descendance est viable alors
il s'agit de la même espèce
et si cette descendance n'est pas viable
ou qu'ils ne sont pas capables de se
reproduire entre eux et bien ces deux
individus appartiennent à des espèces
différentes
voilà donc ça ce sont les trois
définitions majeur d'une espèce il en
existe beaucoup d'autres mais ça c'est
les 3 qu'on utilise le plus souvent et
il n'y en a pas une qui vaut mieux que
l'autre je te vois en commentaire en
train de dire que la définition
biologique est la meilleure non il y en
a pas une qui est meilleur que les
autres la définition biologique aller
absolument inutilisable en paléontologie
et elle est souvent pas utilisable par
les généticiens puisque souvent ils
n'ont qu'un échantillon adn pour décider
de ce qu'ils doivent faire une nouvelle
espèce ou non voilà quand
quand par exemple les scientifiques ont
découvert pour la première fois le
dauphin des îles kiribati et ben il avec
un steak
voilà donc ils ont fait des analyses
génétiques sur le steak de dauphin et
puis ils ont vu que l'adn était
suffisamment différent pour en faire une
nouvelle espèce
donc voilà il avait pas moyen de savoir
si ce dauphin pouvait se reproduire avec
les autres espèces de dauphins déjà
connu quand on dessine une nouvelle
espèce sur la base d'un fossile c'est
pareil on peut pas savoir si ce fossile
été capables de se reproduire avec un
autre fossile déjà connu donc l'espèce
biologique est pas applicable tout le
temps et elle est d'ailleurs pas
applicable dans le cas d espèce aussi en
cercle donc les espèces encerclent ce
sont les espèces qui de proche en proche
sont un terreau fécond
mais par contre les deux espèces qui lie
qui vivent le plus géographiquement
éloignés ne sont pas un terreau fécond
donc voilà de proche en proche les
espèces qui vivent l'une à côté de
l'autre sont un terreau féconde mais les
deux espèces les plus éloignés le sont
pas alors est ce que c'est la même
espèce ou est-ce que c'est pas la même
espèce bah voilà toutes ces définitions
du mot espèces ont leurs avantages et
ont leurs défauts il en a pas une qui
est meilleur que les autres
j'admets que la définition biologique un
penchant moins arbitraire que les autres
mais tout pour être tout à fait honnête
elle est tellement pas facilement
applicables que de toute façon la
question se pose assez rarement de est
ce qu'on choisit telle ou telle
définition de l'espèce en réalité mon
show on prend la définition de l'espèce
qu'on peut utiliser est rarement celle
qu'on veut donc voilà le pouvoir
utiliser la notion d'espèce biologique
techniquement c'est un luxe voilà faut
vraiment avoir les données qu'il faut
pour ça donc voilà aucune de ces
définitions de l'espèce n'est supérieur
à l'autre et donc dans le cas de
néandertal
s'agit-il d'une espèce différente ou non
de homo sapiens eh bien appliquons ces
trois différentes définitions d'espèces
donc la première définition d'espèce
c'est l'espèce morphologiques
historiquement c'est la première qui a
été définie pour l'homme de néandertal
donc homo neandertalensis est
morphologiquement totalement différent
d'homo sapiens je veux dire vous avez
des bourgs les suces orbitaire la forme
plus
oval de la boîte crânienne beaucoup de
détails anatomiques dentaire bref
néandertal
il a beaucoup de différences anatomiques
avec homo sapiens donc du point de vue
de la définition de l'espèce
morphologiques on dirait homo
neandertalensis on a analysé les gènes
de l'homme de néandertal et du point de
vue de la définition génétique il ya
suffisamment de différences entre
l'homme de néandertal est homo sapiens
pour en faire une espèce différente
on peut prendre un bout de deux
séquences génétiques et dire s'il
appartient plus à néanderthal ou plus à
sa place
alors ces deux essais de définition
marche-t-elle toujours quand on a des
hybrides et bien il se trouve qu'on a
des hybrides supposé de néandertal et de
sapiens et que ces hybrides supposé de
néandertal et de sa pièce on arrive à
dire morphologiquement si c'est un
néandertal avec du sapiens dedans c'est
par exemple le cas d'un fossile en
italie qui a tout du néandertal excepté
qu'il a un petit menton et ce petit
menton ça montre qu'il avait quelque
part dans ses ancêtres à saint-piat donc
c'est un néandertal avec du sapiens
hybride est dedans
donc on arrive quand même à dire avec
une certaine confiance
si on est face à un est rien et en
d'herta l'hybride et sapiens sapiens
hybride et néandertal pour les gêner de
la génétique c'est pareil on arrive à
dire si la séquence génétique qu'on
regarde est une séquence de sa place
avec de néandertal dedans ou si c'est
une séquence de néandertal avec du
sapiens dedans
donc même dans les cas d'hybridation on
arrive quand même à faire tenir debout
ces définitions et dans les deux cas on
arrive à dire si ces homo sapiens ou
homo neandertalensis mais il n'y a pas
d'histoire deux sous-espèces d'ailleurs
il ya des grosses discussions sur ce
qu'on veut dire sur une sous-espèce en
paléontologie en paléontologie on
pourrait aussi en discuter mais ça va
pas être le sujet là on va partir du
principe que on a le droit d'appeler
quelque chose une sous-espèce parce que
sinon il n'y a pas débat
voilà c'est tout c'est donc on est bien
par sachant qu'on se pose la question ne
faut-il dire ou non homo sapiens
néandertal n 6 on va partir du principe
qu'on a le droit de le dire et donc homo
neanderthalensis que ce soit pour la
définition génétique ou la définition
morphologique
qu'en est il de la définition biologique
et bien vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
qu'on a découvert depuis 2010 qu'homo
sapiens et que homo neandertalensis été
capable de s'hybrider donc en théorie on
devrait dire homo sapiens
neanderthalensis si et seulement si on
ne considère que la définition
biologique de l'espèce or ce sont les
paléontologues qui parle de homo
neandertalensis et les paléontologues
il utilise principalement la définition
morphologiques donc c'est de là que
vient le débat c'est de là que vient le
débat ça vient de cette de ce conflit en
fait entre la définition morphologiques
et la définition génétique et la
définition biologique pardon donc
normalement si vous êtes comme la
plupart des gens et que vous n'utilisez
que la définition biologique et bien
vous devriez dire homo sapiens
neanderthalensis voilà parce que les
deux espèces sont hybrides à bhl mais
qui en a quand même une qui est
distincte morphologiquement est qui et
qui est représenté par une population
qui est aussi distingue géographiquement
puisque néandertal il vivait en europe
principalement alors que homo sapiens il
vient d'afrique
donc les les deux variants en fait les
deux variants biologique d'homo sapiens
sapiens sapiens en afrique et sapiens
neanderthalensis en europe sont bien
distincts quand même morphologiquement
et géographiquement
donc voila tout dépend en fait de la
définition que vous voulez utiliser de
la notion d'espèce c'est tout le débat
il va pas plus loin que la définition
que vous souhaitez utiliser donc tout le
monde a raison et tout le monde a tort
au final tout dépend où vous voulez en
venir avec votre définition d'espèces
mais à cela se rajoute le concept dole
au type donc on passe à la deuxième
partie de mon argumentaire qui ait
quoique et ses canaux le type un hollow
type c'est le spécimen de référence pour
une espèce c'est à dire que quand vous
définissez une nouvelle espèce vous
désignez un spécimen de référence ça
peut être un crâne ça peut être un
spécimen en paille et ça peut être une
phalange ça peut enfin ce sera
certainement le cas pour denisot vain
puisque denisot va on sait d'ores et
déjà que ça représente une nouvelle
espèce et que jusqu'à présent les seuls
fragments confirmé de denisova basse et
des morceaux de phalanges
il n'y a pas longtemps ils viennent de
trouver une mâchoire qui apparemment a
l'air d'être dû denisot va mais bon
voilà quoi le premier spécimen trouvé et
qui sert de référence à tout le reste
c'est cette phalange donc ce sera
probablement cette phalange qui finira
au le type de homo denisot 26 si jamais
il doit être créé un jour d'ailleurs
c'est probablement de là que vient le
fait qu'on n'a toujours pas donné non à
denisova c'est parce que utiliser une
phalange comme spécimens de référence ça
fait un peu chier surtout du point de
vue morphologique ça fait pas grand
chose à se mettre sous la dent donc bref
et donc il ya conflit du coup entre
l'espèce biologique et l'espèce
génétique et l'espèce morphologiques
dans le cadre denisot va
voilà mais bref je digresse revenons à
notre néandertal donc à naulleau type
c'est un spécimen qui va servir de
référence donc quand on définit une
nouvelle espèce ont défini un hollow
type c'est à dire un spécimen qui va
servir pour toutes les comparaisons
futur c'est à dire que quand vous allez
trouver du nouveau matériel donc je sais
pas moi un nouvel animal vivant ou un
nouveau fossile et bien vous allez
revenir à votre eau le type à votre
spécimens de référence vous allez le
comparer à ce spécimen de référence donc
vous allez comparer sa morphologie si
vous êtes un adepte de la définition de
l'espèce morphologiques vous allez
comparer c'est sa génétique si vous à
nad si vous êtes un adepte de la
définition génétique
vous allez éventuellement essayer une
hybridation si jamais votre le type est
encore vivant mais généralement c'est
pas le cas et mais bon et puis si vous
êtes intelligent vous allez utiliser un
maximum d'indicés un maximum de
définition quoi voilà donc mais vous
reviendrez toujours à ce spécimen pour
décider si oui ou non ce le nouveau
individus que vous avez découvert sont
possibles appartiennent possiblement à
la même espèce que le lot type ou pas
donc un hollow type c'est crucial dans
la définition d'une espèce c'est le plus
c'est l'élément le plus important de la
définition d'une espèce
et il se trouve qu'homo sapiens n'en a
pas en tout cas pas officiellement parce
que jamais personne à hull et les bowls
de se désigner lui-même ou de désigner
quelqu'un d'autre comme au le type
d'homo sapiens donc homo sapiens n'a pas
de spécimens de référence alors il ya
une légende qui circule selon laquelle
carl von linné donc lyn et pour les
intimes qui a lui même donné le nom
binomiale homo sapiens a sa propre
espèce
il ya une rumeur qui dit qu'en gros line
et ce serait définit lui-même comme le
type d'homo sapiens dans un excès de
mégalomanie
c'est pas le cas parce que de toute
façon le concept dole au type
n'existaient pas à l'époque de l'ine
donc il n'a pas pu se définir comme
mollo type en fait la définition de
l'ine comme hollow type d'homo sapiens
parce qu'il est enfin l'ine a réellement
été proposé comme le type d'homo sapiens
mais la décision de désigner line et
comme hollow type d'homo sapiens elle a
bien eu lieu mais elle a eu lieu bien
des années après dans les années 50 dans
les années 1950 un pas à l'époque de
l'hymne est donc dans les années 50
quelqu'un a décidé que l'ine pour le
pour honorer l'ine a décidé que ce
serait line et le type de mots sapiens
le problème ça pourrait ça pourrait
s'arrêter là et on aurait un non loties
pour me sapiens mais le problème c'est
que l'ine il et il n'est pas du tout
dans une institution publique et pour
être valide un hollow type doit être
détenue par une ati institutions
publiques
donc soit une université soit un musée
soit une école primaire enfin ce que
vous voulez mais faut qu'il soit dans
une institution publique
le problème de l'ine c'est qu'il est
enterré dans une cathédrale et en
l'occurrence dans un sarcophage sous une
belle dalle en marbre bref il est
inaccessible
donc ça c'est aussi une autre condition
pour avoir un motif valable
il doit être accessible d'où le fait
d'ailleurs qu'il doit être dans une
institution publique garantissant
l'accessibilité du phosphate pas du
fossile mais du spécimen donc lyn et
c'est pas du tout un bon os le type pour
homo sapiens donc homo sapiens au final
bas il a pas d'eau l'eau type donc c'est
ce qu'on appelle un domaine du biome au
mossad
as le binôme nomenclature à l' homo
sapiens ne peut pas exister en l'absence
de l'eau type par contre néandertal lui
la 1e le type s'agit de bain d'un
fossile que je vais vous montrer à
l'écran il me semble que c'est il me
semble qu'il vient d'allemagne mais je
le précise ray sur l'image donc voilà il
a un hollow type néandertal et comme
néandertal est capable de s'hybrider
avec homo sapiens comme les analyses
génétiques non démontrée et bien si vous
suivez la définition biologie de
l'espèce qui vous est très certainement
très cher et bien homo sapiens doit être
référée à cette eau l'eau type lolo type
de l'homme de néandertal homo sapiens
appartient donc à l'espèce néandertal
homo sapiens et homo neandertalensis ou
si vous tenez absolument à distinguer
homo sapiens de homo neanderthalensis eh
bien il faut appeler homo sapiens et
homo neandertalensis sapiens voilà et
tout ça ça tient au fait qu'il n'ya pas
de l'eau type pour le second pourrait
appeler le genre humain en fait l'espèce
humaine donc le genre humain au mot n'a
pas d'espèces officielle qui s'appelle
sapiens donc ça pias doit être réuni
avec l'espèce la plus proche qui a un os
le type et cette espèce c néandertal et
comme ils sont capables de s'hybrider il
ne s'agit même pas d'une espèce
différente
donc en fait nous sommes nous mêmes des
hommes de néandertal voilà comment
j'arrive à cette conclusion et voilà
comment j'en arrive à la conclusion
qu'en définitive il y aurait mieux fallu
pas se poser la question du tout parce
que la réponse elle est outrageusement
longue et décevante
donc je vous rassure évidemment qu'homo
sapiens est une espèce valide mais pour
que homo sapiens soit une espèce valide
il ya quand même fallu que la commission
internationale de nomenclature fasse une
petite exception avec ses propres règles
voilà avec les règles qu'elle a
elle-même est émise pour que carl von
linné soit considéré comme un hollow
type valide alors qu'en fait la
considération de l'ine comme le type
d'homo sapiens ne devrait pas être
valide si on suit strictement les raies
le du comité de la commission de
nomenclature internationale donc voilà
le fait est que il faut s'accommoder des
règles si on veut considérer homo
sapiens comme une espèce valide donc
voilà il vaut mieux pas se poser trop de
questions
et c'est exactement là quand est arrivée
la commission de nomenclature
internationale
je vous remercie de m'avoir écouté
briser vos rêves et je vous dis à très
bientôt sur notre chaîne ciao
[Musique]